Do you go to mass on
Christmas? No. No Mass at all.
I go to Willy Wonka's golden chocolate
factory. Wow. It's all nonsense, man.
Why would I do that?
I remember I'm just asking tradition
because he grew up that way. No,
I never grew up that way. You
didn't, you were a kid. Yeah, we did.
But it was for a very short amount
of time to say I grew up that way.
It would be hard because it was, I was
out by the time I was at a first grade.
Oh yeah. We're talking about
putting me back in for second grade,
but we moved from New Jersey
to San Francisco and uh,
we didn't find a Catholic school.
And Catholic schools costs money too.
You know what? The public school after
that, but I was just done. I hated it.
I was in fear of those
fucking crazy people.
And your parents didn't take
you to church or make you good?
They did a little bit. I think the idea
was back then, that if you had kids,
he wanted kids go to Catholic school.
You know,
there's a lot of people that did that
in that neighborhood when I was little.
It was just a normal thing you did. Yeah.
And they were more strict and to dude,
one thing that was for sure though,
like I had a conversation with my mom
about it once, she was like, you know,
your grades were way better when
you went into your Catholic school.
And I was like, yeah, cause it was
fucking terrified to get wrong.
They beat the shit out of you want to
live like that. They never beat me.
They definitely threatened
me. Really? Yeah.
They threatened to make
me sit on the nail.
I'm going to have to sit on a nail and the
uh, in the closet, stay here all night.
I hope you brought your blanket.
They're like really mean when you're
like a little six year old kid.
Like that's fucked up.
It's just a weird, oh this,
we stuck with these people
for nine months and to also,
for me it's like my parents
are splitting up at the time.
So it was very confusing and then I
wanted things to have order to them.
So I wanted God to make sense. I
remember annoying people with that. Yeah.
I'm like six years old. I didn't annoy
people talking about what God wants.
What do you mean? Like you,
God says this, God wants that.
Like I would say that six years old
because I was a little kid who was dealing
with my parents splitting up and there
didn't seem to be any order in the world
and it was very nervous. Right? So when I
finally, when I went to Catholic school,
when I first got there,
I was,
I was happy that it was going
to go to Catholic school.
But then as I experienced it
at six years old, I started
going, this is ridiculous.
This doesn't make any sense. I'm like,
first of all, these people are so mean.
They're, they're obviously being mean
and nasty. They're not comforting.
And I was thinking as a six
year old comparing them the
way like my grandma was,
and my mother was like, these are,
these ladies were nasty and so mean.
And I'm like, these, they don't represent
God. And I was like, this is crazy sex.
And then you could see kids getting in
trouble because their parents hadn't paid
for their lunch or this guy
and it was like this really,
you tell your father to get that money in.
Like there was a weirdness to it that
just didn't seem loving or it didn't seem
like what I thought of when I thought of,
you know,
Christ and when I thought of
it seemed to me like, oh no,
this is a dark little trap.
Get sucked into.
That's what's remarkable about
that is not just the age,
but that you went from a really,
really needing it in a very
real way because what was
happening with your family
to like normally you
wouldn't turn that quickly.
Like within a year it
sounds like, or two. Yeah,
it was over by the time
I was out of there.
Usually that change doesn't happen for
1520 years outside of beating me or doing
something sexual to me, the, this,
the mind fuck of dealing with those mean
nasty ladies scare the shit out of me
crying and they were calling me a baby
cause I was crying. I was like, whoa.
It's just not knowing how to
deal with human beings. Yeah.
When you're a six year old and
this is going down and you're like,
what have I done?
Yeah.
Like I went from always being with
my mom or being with my grandma,
my grandfather. I was
like, everything's cool.
And then all of a sudden you're going to
school and this is what you're doing in
school. I didn't go to
kindergarten. I went to first grade.
It was the first thing I went to.
Right.
So all of a sudden the first grade is
like instantaneously being connected to
these crazy ladies. She's,
I was like, oh no poor.
And then I would think about them.
I don't think what kind of like,
and I was thinking about
why this will mean,
I remember being like six years old
thinking this right. I'm just like,
nobody probably loves them. Like they
don't get, they don't have a family.
I have a boyfriend. I didn't think at
the time they don't have a girlfriend,
but maybe they do Holla. Right.
But for sure they didn't.
The whole thing was that they didn't,
you know, they didn't have anything.
No connection with another human being
to be lonelier or more angered inducing.
Yeah. It was just dark. They
weren't, they weren't loving people.